Let's now use our
understanding of some
of the operations on sets
to get some blood flowing
to our brains.
So I've defined some sets here.
And just to make
things interesting,
I haven't only put
numbers in these sets.
I've even put some colors and
some little yellow stars here.
And what I want
you to figure out
is what would this set
be, this crazy thing that
involves relative complements,
intersections, unions,
absolute complements.
So I encourage you
to pause it and try
to figure out what
this set would be.
Well, let's give it a shot.
And the key here is to
really break it down, work
on the stuff in the
parentheses first,
just as you would do
if you were trying
to parse a traditional
mathematical statement.
And then it should hopefully
make a little bit of sense.
So a good place
to start might be
to try to figure out what is the
relative complement of C in B.
Or another way of thinking
about it is what is B minus C?
What is B if you take out
all the stuff with C in it?
So let me write this down.
The relative complement
of C and B or you
could call this B minus C.
This is all the stuff in B
with all the stuff
in C taken out of it.
So let's think about
what this would be.
B has a 0.
Does C have a 0?
No, so we don't have
to take out the 0.
B has a 17.
Does C have a 17?
Yes, it does.
So we take out the 17.
B has a 3, but c has a 3.
So we take that out.
B has a Blue.
C does not have a blue.
So we leave the Blue in.
So let me write down--
we leave the blue in.
And then B has a gold star.
C also has a gold star.
So we take the gold star out.
So the relative complement of
C in B is just the set of 0
and this Blue written in blue.
So let me write this down.
Let me write that down.
Now, it gets interesting.
We're going to take the
absolute complement,
the absolute complement of that.
So let me write this down.
So B-- the absolute
complement of this business
is going to be-- let me write
it this-- the set of all things
in our universe that are
neither a 0 or a-- and I'll
write it in blue-- or a Blue.
That's the only way I could
describe it right now.
I haven't really defined
the universe well.
We already see that
our universe definitely
contains some integers,
it contains colors,
it contains some stars.
So this is all I can really say.
This is the set of all things
in the universe that are neither
a 0 or a Blue.
So fair enough.
So we so far we figured
out all of this stuff.
Let me box this off.
So that is that
right over there.
And now we want to
find the intersection.
We need to find the intersection
of A and this business.
Let me write that down.
So it's going to
be A intersected
with the relative
complement of C and B
and the absolute
complement of that.
So this is going to be the
intersection of the set
A and the set of all things in
the universe that are neither
a 0 or a Blue.
So it's essentially
the things that
satisfy both of these
that has to be in set A
and it has to be in
the set of all things
in the universe that are
neither a 0 or a blue.
So let's think
about what this is.
So the number 3 is in set A and
it's in the set of all things
in the universe that
are neither a 0 or Blue.
So let's throw a 3 in there.
The number 7, it's in
A and it's in the set
of all things in the universe
that are neither a 0 or a Blue.
So let's put a 7 there.
Negative 5 also meets
that constraint.
A 0 does not meet
A 0 is in A but
it's not in the set
of all things in the
universe that are neither
a 0 or blue because it is a 0.
So we're not going
to throw 0 in there.
And then a 13 is in
A and it's in the set
of all things in the universe
that are neither a 0 or a Blue.
So we could throw a 13 in there.
So we've simplified
things a good bit.
This whole crazy business,
all of this crazy business,
has simplified to this
set right over here.
Now we want to find the relative
complement of this business
in A. So let me pick
another color here.
So we want to find the relative
complement of this business
in A. And I'll just write out
the set-- 3, 7, negative 5, 13.
Actually, let me
write out both of them
just so that we can
really visualize
them both right over here.
So A is this.
It is 3, 7, negative
5, 0, and 13.
And I could write the
relative complement sign.
Or actually, let me
just write m-- well
let me write
relative complement.
I was going to write minus.
And so in all of this business,
we already figured out,
is a 3, a 7, a
negative 5, and a 13.
So it's essentially,
start with this set
and take out all the stuff
that are in this set.
So this is going to
be equal to-- so you
see we're going to have to
take out a 3 out of this set.
We're going to take out a 7.
We're going to get a negative 5.
And we're going
to take out a 13.
So we're just left with
the set that contains a 0.
So all of this business
right over here
has simplified to a set
that only contains a 0.
Now let's think about
what B intersect C is.
These are all the things
that are in both B and C.
So this is going to be B
intersect C. Let's see,
0 is not in both of them.
17 is in both of them.
So we'll throw 17 in there.
The number 3 is in both
of them, the number 3
is in both of them.
Blue is not in both of them.
The star is in both of them.
So I'll put the little
gold star right over there.
And so that's B intersect C.
And so we're essentially
going to take
the union of this crazy
thing-- which ended up just
being a set with a 0 in it--
we're taking the union of that
and B intersect C. We
deserve a drum roll now.
This is all going to be
equal to-- we're just
going to combine these two sets.
It's going to be the set
with a 0, a 17, a three,
and our gold star.
And we are-- I should make the
brackets in a different color--
and we are done.